bonjour on dit souvent de ne pas
commencer un toc par une statistique ou
par un chiffre donc je vais commencer
par un chiffre jetons un chiffre
pourquoi je présente ce chiffre est là
il est assez populaire c'est le chiffre
le plus trendy du moment 4.0 et on dit
qu'on est à l'époque 4.0 l'industrie 4.0
la robotique 4.0 c'est pratiquement
sinon céréales sont pas rendus 4.0 ceci
dit pour la nature humaine ma prétention
c'est qu'on est loin d'être à 4.0 on est
plutôt à 1.4 qu'est ce que je veux dire
par là on ne le même système
opérationnel qu'on a toujours eue on
appelle le système de l'homo economicus
on un peu optimisé avec le temps on se
rend compte que ça fonctionne pas donc
là notre réflexe est de passer en point
51.6 mais la croyance de base à ce
système là est complètement flou et donc
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de réfléchir
aux conséquences de cette perception là
ce que je fais dans la vie donc j'ai
utilisé dans le domaine des ressources
humaines
mon but était d'améliorer le climat de
travail dans les entreprises
j'ai jamais su de quel côté je voulais
me positionner syndicats ou employeurs
donc j'ai fait le choix de ne pas
choisir
je suis resté des deux côtés et j'essaie
d'aider les organisations à améliorer
leur climat de travail
c'est ce qu'on appelle un jeu à somme
non nul c'est à dire que tout le monde
peut en bénéficient on a beaucoup de
problèmes dans les organisations
actuellement pas plus tard que cette
semaine une étude de montrer que la
mobilisation dans les entreprises avant
qu'à diminuer la confiance envers les
dirigeants et les institutions à
diminuer aussi les problèmes de santé
mentale au travail sont en explosion
donc comme dirait l'autre pas besoin
d'être le pogo le plus dégelée de la
boîte pour savoir que ça va peut-être
pas si bien que ça et le le problème
pour moi y est beaucoup plus un problème
de croyance qu'on a que de changer le
système faut d'abord changer nos
croyances
donc pour changer ses croyances le jeu
nous invite à suivre un personnage ok
pour la fin de l'exercice aujourd'hui un
personnage que
je vais appeler antoine antoine y étant
un peu comme tous un peu comme tout nous
autres finalement il se dit dans la vie
pour avoir du succès est ce que je dois
faire ma place me battre c'est la jungle
c'est wall street où je dois être
généreux aider les autres connecter avec
les gens
donc qu'est ce qui va me permettre
d'avoir du succès et c'est normal qu'ils
se posent cette question là parce que si
on regarde l'image disons que la société
nous envoie on peut penser que
l'instrument et à nous écouter
il ressemble à ça c'est ce qu'on entend
d'ailleurs je vous invite à faire le
test chez vous promenez vous dans la rue
ce soir et dit à n'importe qui c'est fou
hein
le monde est rendu fou il va vous être
raison on est tous d'accord avec ça
quand en réalité pourtant tous les
indicateurs de qualité de vie nous
disent que les choses s'améliorent donc
en réalité pendant que les choses
s'améliorent dans la société où l'être
humain est beaucoup plus empreint de
beauté ou d'altruisme qu'on peut
imaginer
c'est l'image qu'on se fait renvoyer et
ça fait du sens parce que les
pessimistes
on l'avait plus intelligent certaines
études disent c'est comme si les
pessimistes
eux ils connaissent ils savent la faire
tandis que les optimistes sont un peu
naïf ti c'est ce qui m'amène à vous dire
que la société d'aujourd'hui est un peu
paranoïaque
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le mot
paranoïa c'est l'idée qu'ont une
méfiance excessive à l'égard de menaces
réelles ou imaginaires donc à nous
regarder aller à penser que tout le
monde est fou tout le monde vit
uniquement centrée sur ses propres
intérêts comme la théorie de l'homo
economicus nous le dit on est devenu un
peu paranoïaque et ça a des conséquences
sur nos vies sur notre santé sur notre
succès sur le bonheur même des individus
pour étudier la nature humaine vous
invite à étudier une émotion que vous ne
connaissez sûrement pas schaden freud
c'est un mot allemand et je ne vais pas
traduit qu'il n'y a aucune traduction en
français pour ce mot là parce que c'est
tabou comme émotion c'est le plaisir que
nous éprouvons avoir quelqu'un se
planter
donc à main levée qui ici a déjà éprouvé
cette émotion là donc si vous voulez
savoir qui est menteur dans la salle ce
qu'ils ont fait lever la main vous le
savez donc cette émotion là tu es pas de
nom est très présent il ya des études
sérieuses là dessus c'est passionnant a
dévoré la littérature sur le chat donne
freud à elodie ben l'être humain
finalement voyez il ya des files à être
humain pourquoi on éprouverait du
plaisir avoir déjà échoué
toutes les vidéos de faire sur internet
d'ailleurs qui nous font beaucoup de
plaisir c'est un peu frustré house a dit
c'est un peu ça nous racines libre de
penser pourtant c'est exactement le
contraire le chat donne freud est une
émotion très relié à l'amour
donc laissez moi vous expliquer ça je
vous mets devant le scénario fictif avec
antoine encore une fois antoine
travaille dans une agence de pub et le
son patron pour une compagnie qui lui a
demandé une publicité a trouvé un slogan
mais un peu sexiste et donc antoine dit
à son patron c'est une mauvaise idée est
une mauvaise idée ça va servir et
contenus
le patron fait son fanfaron puis il faut
du courage dans la vie et finalement
comme de fait mauvaise des publicitaires
il se plante et donc le camp
l'entreprise se met à capoter ils
viennent voir l' agence de pub
qu'est ce que le patron fait est dû et
antoine je pense à ça je t'ai pas au
courant du tout c'est de sa faute donc
antoine étaient habitués qu'ils sont aux
boss lui vole ses idées mais le disons
que ça dépasse un peu les bornes et à
moins d'être le dalaï lama en général
vous allez ressentir une émotion
négative donc la semaine suivante
antoine fallait quand même qui garde sa
job décide d'aller jouer au golf avec
son patron quai antoine salut et là
antoine
évidemment c'est son patron qui peut pas
lui dire vraiment le fond de sa pensée
ceci dit on ne plus avoir accès à son
cerveau il voir exactement ce qui se
passe dans son cerveau pensez vous
vraiment qu'il veut que qu'il veut que
son patron réussi son coup donc
regardons l'extrait vidéo donc antoine
se dit oui c'était un bon gars moi c'est
pas vrai que j'suis pas plein de bonté à
l'intérieur de moi
mais disons que j'aimerais ça qu'il
manque son coup juste le fait d'imaginer
de fantasmer sur le fait que son patron
allemand à qui ça nous fait du bien et
quand finalement on voit qu'il me
manquait on éprouve une décharge intense
de plaisir
cette décharge intense de plaisir au
fond est-ce que donc antoine aime voir
les gens souffrir
pas du tout antoine est amoureux de la
justice ayant vu la justice triomphé
devant ses yeux tout simplement
donc c'est un désir profond de justice
auquel ont eu accès d'ailleurs
l'antithèse du schadenfreude qu'est ce
que ce serait prenons un autre exemple
totalement opposé antoine regarde les
olympiques quelques années et joannie
rochette et aux olympiques vous le savez
son histoire et deux jours avant sa
prestation sa maman décède et elle
décide avec courage de quand même allé
faire sa prestation et de se présenter
au milieu de la glace est donc là
antoine comme la majorité d'entre vous
quand joannie rochette a exécuté sa
prestation et qu'elle a fait le son le
plus difficile on était soulagé quand
elle est réussie on était tous de son
côté si vous aviez le goût qu'elle tombe
je suis pas médecin mais vous devrez
peut-être d'aller consulter hockey et
c'est quoi que vous avez éprouvé keller
réussie vous avez sauté dans les bras de
votre voisin on était tous contents on
éprouver de l'empathie au fond et
l'empathie c'est celle inverse
finalement de schadenfreude c'est l'idée
qu'on éprouve du plaisir profond à voir
les gens réussir qu'on sent qu'ils l'ont
mérité
regardez donc la nature humaine
finalement elle est plus positive qu'on
peut penser des fois par contre le chah
donne frais de ces pots ac c'est le fun
d'éprouver du plaisir à voir les gens se
planter mais c'est plus le fun quand on
passe nous mêmes à l'action c'est ce qui
s'appelle se faire justice
la revanche la revanche à première vue
là je vous demanderai pas de lever la
main pour savoir qui s'est déjà venger
mais on l'a tous déjà fait la revanche a
peut être explosif comme ça peut être
des petites actions quotidiennes
l'idée au fond de la revanche c'est quoi
c'est de restaurer l'équité et la
justice dans la souffrance
tu me fais payer le prix mais je vais
rétablir l'équilibré
je vais me rembourser par exemple donc
je pense rien de vous dire que vous
devez vous venger et y les études le
montrent d'ailleurs que de pardonner une
fois ou deux avant de penser à la
revanche et même encore mieux et plus
optimale ceci dit les gens qui se venge
faut pas les voir comme des gens qui
sont trop altruiste au contraire à la
littérature anglophone nous parle
d'altruiste hic management ou de morale
revenge se serait même immoral de ne pas
se venger
c'est ce qu'on se dit au fond par
exemple quand vous faites un commentaire
sur internet pour vous plaindre contre
une compagnie ou un professeur par
exemple mais ce que vous faites c'est
purement altruiste vous aviser les gens
qui vont passer après vous d'être
prudent donc vous contribuez à la
cohésion sociale en réalité la revanche
ça peut être des grandes choses mais des
fois c'est des choses extrêmement simple
par exemple le barista qui dit moi les
clients et polis ils savent quoi là je
leur donne du café décaféiné dans leurs
dents
j'ai voulu être impoli donc ça peut être
des petites choses comme ça vous vous
vengez chaque jour même sans le savoir
et c'est ça la main invisible au fond
vous contribuerez à ça par exemple le
gossip le commérage lemay mirage appelez
le comme vous voulez on dit que le deux
tiers de nos conversations dans la vie
sur les enregistrer c'est du même et
rage mais c'est quoi du mirage ça sert
une fonction sociale importante vous
jasez de à qui faire attention à qui
vous pouvez faire confiance et à qui ne
pas faire confiance
donc si on ne le faisait pas mais les
tricheurs sentir est culte donc le
gossip
on a fait ça depuis des millénaires même
les singes enfants oms a averti va pas
chasser avec lui il partagera pas avec
toi je t'invite donc en réalité même le
même et rage une fonction sociale donc
la revanche c'est pratiquement de
l'altruisme autant vous êtes prêt à
provoquer le karmapa ce qu'on croit pas
toujours au karma 11il on se disait dans
le passé on va régler ça en fer ou
paradis les jeunes font plus confiance
en nous on veut régler son issue
en glissant sur terre donc on veut
provoquer le carrément pour nourrir à
l'autre mais à l'opposé avec les gens
qui le méritent
on va provoquer le carmin même au
détriment de nos intérêts personnels
pour les aider d'où la bonté et la
générosité de la plupart des êtres
humains quand on parlait d' empathie
tout à l'heure mais l'empathie sans
empathie on pourrait pas survivre parce
que l'être humain
maurer cahier seule personne à être
humain tout seul il meurt nous sommes
interdépendants et cette interdépendance
cela nous oblige à être intéressés aux
émotions des autres c'est ce qui nous a
fait survivre dans le passé et sans
cette émotion aulas il y aurait plus de
sociétés par exemple quand on parle de
revanche des fois vous vous dites non je
le fais parce que ça me fait plaisir ça
me fait du bien
mais justement votre corps est programmé
pour vous aider à éprouver ces émotions
là à vous dire c'est de la vengeance
mais altruiste au fond donc en réalité
vous le saviez peut-être pas mais vous
êtes la police du karma et la police du
caire n'a d'ailleurs radiohead avait une
chanson là dessus et quand on regarde
les palais les paroles qu'est ce qu'il
nous dit déçu soit you get one you may
well as dans le fond donc on va aider
les gens où on va leur nourrir
dépendamment de commun ils nous ont
traités
c'est plus fort que nous on s'en rend
même pas compte de mon participation
quels sont les impacts de ça en réalité
donc puisque ça nous dit soyez faire
soyez juste avec les autres pas besoin
de les motiver de les inspirer de tirer
le meilleur déjà on a tout simplement
besoin de justes et on voit des bars et
le potentiel de nos relations humaines
c'est le fun comment on fait pour être
juste mais la science répondu à cette
question là c'est assez sain
rien de compliqué il me faut être
rigoureux dans l'application de sa
l'équité l'inclusion et la considération
donc l'équité
on échange c'est donnant donnant c'est
pas juste prendre dans leurs relations
tout donne aussi l'inclusion
quand on prend des décisions je te
consult je pense que tu es un membre à
part entière de notre communauté et la
considération vous pouvez l'appeler
bienveillant est-ce que tu une traite
avec respect et dignité par exemple
car ces trois éléments sont présents ils
vont tous se renforcer je me dis ben
t'es juste est située juste mais je vais
tout faire pour t'aider
s'ils forment dans mon domaine j'étudie
cette question là donc c'est le fun de
reach et pour l'importance de la justice
mais les données le monde
si on regarde la science sur cette
question là elle nous dit non seulement
c'est positif on peut même aller plus
loin
la générosité la gratitude la
gentillesse être gentil est ce que ça
nous permet d'avoir du succès les études
nous disent que oui
et ces éléments là on passe à nous
permettre de vivre plus vieux comme si
notre corps nous remercier d'avoir cet
état d'esprit-là la littérature
scientifique nous a informés sur cette
question là depuis longtemps
donc la question est réglée c'est pas
une question d'opinion que je vous
présente aujourd'hui c'est relié à tous
ces éléments là dans la littérature la
confiance la qualité de la relation
l'engagement la performance on cherche
toutes ces choses lorsqu'on vend dans
les entreprises qu'on n'y arrive pas
faut revenir à la base c'est traiter les
gens avec justice à l'opposé par contre
quand la justice est absente épuisement
professionnel maladies cardiovasculaires
insomnie inflammation aux auditeurs soit
seul ou dans les vols on viendrait des
cellules pour verrez qu'elle sauf
lorsqu'elles l'injustice et tous les
comportements négatifs de sabotage de
comportements déviants de roulement
d'absentés la science nous montre ça
quand je rentre dans des entreprises des
téléphones la science mais chez nous ce
qu'on demande en réalité garder juste
dans des entreprises que j'étudie ce
qu'on découpe car le niveau de justice
est très fort les gens vont bien donc
vous regardez là on est inspirée
enthousiaste on est joyeux c'est le fun
ou casser un peu moins injuste on se
garde une petite gêne
on sait plus on devrait te faire
confiance et kayes pas de justice car
c'est encore plus faible on a des
émotions purement négative et ses
émotions l'onou dessus donc l'injustice
tue littéralement même chose pour les
comportements qu'on va rechercher dans
les entreprises par exemple on va
espérer avoir de l'engagement les gens
qui restent la loyauté de l'innovation
mais les gens auront paul goude
novaes pour toi si tu les traite pas
avec justice ont compris implanter des
patente à gosses des tables de ping pong
en réalité les gens veulent juste être
traiter avec justice ils vont se donner
pour toi donc il me semble que c'est
simple et regarder sur les comportements
négatifs quatre fois plus présent cahier
injustice donc me semble que au regard
de ce qu'on dit c'est trop beau pour
être vrai on a tendance à sous-estimer
l'importance du contexte et à surestimer
la personnalité si vous allez voir un
chef d'entreprise qui vise selon lui dit
le monde a pas d'accord comme je vous ai
dit au début de la présentation
en réalité c'est la façon dont les
autres traités j'aime bien la citation
de djordje karlen quitte un humoriste
américain qui dit avez vous remarqué que
sur la route les gens qui conduisent
moins vite que vous sont des idiots
parce qu'au delà et ceux qui conduisent
plus vite que vous sont des maniaques
donc tout le monde il faut à part nous
faut arrêter de voir ça comme ça et de
se dire les gens réagissent de façon
contextuelle relié à la façon dont on
les traite
autre raison pourquoi on n'accorde pas
assez d'importance à cette théorie là
c'est que ça se vend pas on peut ou
vendre sauf de choses à la bise la
consultation vous vendre des méthodes
des techniques des programmes la justice
basse et humains stand nous appartient à
personne la générosité
ben c'est facile à donner tout
simplement
donc on est un peu paranoïaque d'une
certaine façon quand on regarde ces
résultats là on aurait juste à traiter
les gens autrement ça fonctionnerait
donc si je pouvais vous donner un
conseil pour terminer aujourd'hui c'est
de pu être paranoïaque sur la nature
humaine
la façon dont on traite les gens vont
nous être remboursés ce soit y aura
toujours des gens qui vont abuser de
votre gentillesse faut penser à long
terme on va se planter sur des petites
occasions en ayant fait trop confiance
par exemple mais sur cinq à dix ans vous
allez toujours gagner donc au lieu
d'être paranoïaque je vous invite à être
un peu plus pro noailhac
si vous avez déjà entendu ce mot là bas
la prono ya c'est l'idée que le monde
conspirent pour nous a aidés donc vous
promener aujourd'hui vous êtes dans
l'état d'esprit
que tout le monde veut vous avez vu le
trou vous a aidé les spécialistes voient
ça comme une maladie le premier temps
c'est discuter comme une maladie
pourtant quand on regarde la littérature
quand on regarde la science qu'on
regarde le data puisque vous avez au
fond de vos coeurs il semble qu'elle
prône aurillac c'est peut-être pas si
fou que ça finalement
merci jean françois bertholet
m